You know what,
one of the things that I've been struck
very hard by a number of writers,
Carl Young,
obviously among them,
I mean he,
he wrote things like Nicha that if you
understand them,
they just break you into pieces,
you know,
and,
and one of the things that young
understood in the psychoanalysts
understand it's one of the most
terrifying elements of psychoanalytic
thinking is very tightly allied with
religious thinking,
which is that you are not the master of
your own house.
There are spirits that dwelling within
you,
meaning you have a will and you can
exercise a certain amount of conscious
control over your being,
but there are all sorts of things that
occur within you that seemed to be
beyond your capacity to control your
dreams.
For example,
that's a really good example.
Are Your impulses.
For example,
you might,
you might think of those as so foreign
from you that they're not even.
You don't even want them to be part of
you,
but,
but more subtly even.
How about what you're interested in,
what compels you?
Like,
where does that come from?
Exactly.
Because you can't.
God,
you can't conjure it up of your own
accord,
you know,
so if you're a student in your taking
difficult course,
you might say to yourself,
well,
I need to sit down and study for three
hours,
but then you sit down and that is what
happens.
Your attention goes everywhere and you
might say,
well,
whose attention is it?
Then?
If it goes everywhere because you say
it's your attention,
it's like,
well,
if it's your attention,
maybe you will be able to control it,
but you can't.
And so then you might think,
well jen and just exactly what the hell
is controlling it.
And you might say,
well,
it's random.
It's better not be random.
I can tell you that that's,
that happens to some degree in
schizophrenia.
There's an element of randomness in
that.
It's not random,
it's driven by the action of,
of phenomena that I think are best
considered as something like
subpersonalities or they'll even.
That's only a partial description.
You can't make yourself interested in
something.
Interest manifests itself in grips you.
That's a whole different thing.
And so what is it that's gripping you
and how do you conceptualize that?
Is that a divine power?
Well,
it's defined as far as you're concerned
because it grips you and you can't do
anything about it,
and so there's a calling in you towards
what you're compelled by and what you're
interested in that sometimes that might
be very dark and sometimes not,
but you're compelled forward by your
interest and so and so the idea that
what moves you away from your country
and your father's house and the comforts
of your childhood home is,
is something that's beyond you and that
you listened to and Harken to.
That's exactly right.
And you can say,
well,
I don't want to call that God.
It's like it doesn't matter what you
call it.
Exactly.
It doesn't matter to what it is,
what it's called.
It still is,
and if you don't listen to it,
that's the other thing.
If you don't listen to it,
and I've been a clinician and talked to
enough people now as old as I am to know
this.
Absolutely.
If you do not to that thing that beckons
you forward,
you will pay for it like you cannot
possibly imagine.
You'll have everything that's terrible
about life in your life and nothing
about it that's good and worse.
You'll know that it was your fault and
that you squandered what you could have
had.